*Introduction* À travers, les époques, les dangers,  une grande aventure les appelle, c'est... L'ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE !
"Voix off" : Après avoir aidé les mayas face à l'invasion Espagnole
Non pardon, nos amis n'ont pas du tout aidé les mayas,
Ils ont fuit l'époque
En laissant tout le monde se faire massacrer
Iris, Thomas, Éliott et la Buse.
arrivent désormais dans une nouvelle époque
*bruitage de téléportation*
"Thomas" : Oh il fait chaud ici hein !
"La Buse" : Raaah du sable dans mes bottes j'deteste ça !!
"Thomas" : Pis y'a rien autour de nous à part.. du sable !
"La Buse" : Si seulement je pouvais tuer le sable !
"Eliott" : Nous sommes en Egypte, il y a précisément... très longtemps.
"Iris" : Eh ben Elliot, t'as changé !
Tu fais plus d'effort !
"Eliott" : Désolé, mais il fait chaud, et je vois bien qu'à chaque fois, vous vous en foutez de la date.
Je détecte des présences humaines derrière cette dune.
"Iris" :Oh super, c'est peut-être enfin mon père !
"Egyptien 1" : Eh, t'en est où dans ton histoire ?
"Iris" : Ah bah non, pas du tout, c'est des égyptiens.
"Egyptien 2" : Attends, le mec, il m'envoie un message, tu sais ce qu'il me dit ?
Faucon vers la gauche, serpent, plume, plume.
"Egyptien 1" : Ah ouais ? Et tu lui as répondu quoi ?
"Egyptien 2" : Bah, tu me connais, j'ai le sang chaud, je lui envoie : Pied, lion, bonhomme vers la droite.
"Egyptien 1" : Hoho, ah ouais, t'es comme ça, toi !
"Iris" : Euh, excusez-moi...
"Egyptien 1" : Eh sinon, ton fils, ça va ?
"Egyptien 2" : Oh là là, m'en parle pas de lui ! Le petit reste scotcher sur son papyrus.
"Egyptien 1" : ah bah j'ai le même à la maison.
À notre époque on avait des gravures sur des pierres ça nous allait très bien
"Iris" : *Toussotement* Excusez moi.
Et là maintenant ils sont absorbés par leur papyrus, ils se parlent même plus.
"La Buse" : Hey ! Les deux chiures de gouvernail.
"Egyptien 2" : Eh, bon ça va, deux secondes quoi, vous voulez quoi ?
"Iris" : Eh, beh, on cherche un homme avec un long manteau blanc qui ..
"Egyptien 2" : Bon si vous voulez des informations faut demander à la reine, voila vous prenez tout droit, deuxième à droite, quatrième sur votre gauche.
"Thomas" : Ouais, ouais mais euh, je vois pas de route moi.
"Egyptien 2" : Des quoi ? Non on parle des dunes, vous pouvez pas louper c'est la première pyramide.
"Eliott" : Vous pensez que la reine voudra bien nous recevoir ?
"Egyptien 2" : Oui, bon moi je vous conseille, vous arrivez vous vous proposez comme esclave sexuel *rire* ça marche à chaque coup ça.
"La Buse" : Ouuuh, cette reine m'intéresse fortement.
*bruitage d'une porte*
"Cleopatre" : Oui entrez !
"Iris" : Ma chère reine ?
"Cleopatre" : Qui êtes-vous ?
"Iris" : Nous sommes des visiteurs et comme preuve de bienveillance, nous vous offrons cet esclave sexuel..
"La Buse" : *rire* Tout à fait. Qui veut mon corps ? C'est toi ma coquine ?
"Iris" : Vous m'en direz des nouvelles.
"Cleopatre" : Quel beau morceau, viril, ça change des brindilles de mon royaume. Vous avez toute mon attention
"Iris" : Reine Cléopâtre, nous cherchons quelqu'un dans les environs. Un homme, en blouse blanche, peut-être..
"Cleopatre" : Ça ne me dit rien ! Maintenant mon beau mâle, enlève tes vêtements et montre moi ta grosse..
"Iris" : Vous vous êtes sur ?! Il a probablement donné une relique à quelqu'un ici..
"Cleopatre" : Non ! Non non non non ! Ne dite pas ce mot. L'autre va encore débouler avec ses énigmes à la con. * bruit de pas rapide *
"Imhotep" : On a parler d'une relique ? Mais ouuiii ! J'ai ce que vous cherchez. *rire* Elle m'a été donner par un dieu en blanc !
"Imhotep" : J'ai pour mission de la garder précieusement ! Il vous faudra la mériter.
"Cleopatre" : Voici Imhotep, un cousin..
"Imhotep" : Mais non ! Il ne faut pas dire mon nom ! Ça casse le mystère. Mais il se trouve que j'ai un chiffre après mon nom. *rire* Celui qui trouve pourra me suivre dans le..
"Cleopatre" : 12 ! C'est Imhotep12 !
"Imhotep12" : Mais non ! Le mystère ! Il faut garder le mystère !
"Imhotep12" : Bon bah, voila c'est moi, Imhotep12.
"Eliott" : Enchanté KB28.
"Thomas" : Thomas54 !
"Iris" : Bon écoutez ! Comment on peut récupérer cette relique ?
"Imhotep12" : *Rire un peu fou* Comme c'est excitant ! Il suffit de résoudre les énigmes que j'ai savamment construite dans les profondeurs de cette pyramide.
"Imhotep12" : Au bout du parcours, se trouve ce que vous cherchez..
"Cleopatre" : Parfait ! Vous suivez mon cousin flippant ! Et quand à toi homme viril ...
"La Buse" : Oh oui ! On a plein de chose à se montrer ma cochonne !
*bruit de pas en continu*
"Thomas" : Ça fait combien de temps qu'on marche la ? En plus je vois rien dans ce couloir à la con.
"Imhotep12" : Nous arriverons bientôt à la première épreuve ! J'en suis très fier ! Personne n'a réussi à la résoudre, vous n'avez aucune chance.
"Iris" : Oh merde, je suis nulle en logique, Eliott on compte sur toi sinon on est foutu.
"Thomas" : Ah bah merci, je n'existe même plus
"Imhotep12" : Nous y voila ! *rire encore un peu fou* Pour ouvrir la porte en pierre, il faut résoudre la puissante énigme que j'ai confectionné.
"Iris" : Eliott ! On compte sur toi !
"Thomas" : Attendez la c'est super simple, il y a une torche allumée à gauche de la porte et une éteinte à droite. Hop je prend la torche de gauche et j'allume celle de droite.
*Bruit de la porte en pierre qui s'ouvre*
"Imhotep12" : Quoi ?!
*Petit bruit Zelda*
"Thomas" : Sympa la musique Eliott.
"Eliott" : J'ai pas pu m'en empêcher
"Imhotep12" : Mais comment vous avez deviner ?! Mais comment c'est possible ?! Ah je vois, un coup de chance. Ça peut arriver même au plus stupide.
"Imhotep12" : Très bien, vous pouvez continuer, de toute façon vous ne passerez jamais la deuxième épreuve. Eh bah d'ailleurs, elle est juste devant vous.
"Iris" : Quoi ? Le couloir là ?
"Imhotep12" : Exactement ! Il suffit de traverser le couloir, allez-y. *rire fou encore une fois*
"Iris" : Ben, ok!
"Thomas" : Non non non Iris ! Mais qu'est-ce tu fais, n'importe quoi.
"Iris" : Bah quoi ?
"Thomas" : Bah t'as faillit tomber dans le trou !
"Iris" : Mais quel trou ?
"Imhotep12" : Mais, mais de quoi parlez-vous ? Il, il n'y a aucun trou..
"Thomas" : Mais regarde devant, au sol la terre elle est retournée, la texture est différente, à tout les coups c'est un trou avec des pics au fond.
"Imhotep12" : Mais pas du tout allez-y marcher droit devant !
*Bruitage de téléportation*
"Aliénor" : Et redevenir la reine pour mes sujets..
"Imhotep12" : Quoi mais mais qui est cette femme qui vient d'apparaitre au bout du couloir ?
"Aliénor" : ( Quoi ?! mais ou suis-je encore? ) Dame Iris ? c'est vous Dame Iris ?
"Eliott" : On dirait le retour d'Aliénor.
"Thomas" : Ah bah c'est parfait !
"Aliénor" : C'est sombre..
"Thomas" : Aliénor !
"Aliénor" : Je n'y vois rien.
"Thomas" : Aliénor viens par ici !
"Aliénor" : Qu'avez vous dit ?
"Thormas" : Aller viens !
"Aliénor" : Je m'approche de vous la.
"Thomas" : Vous allez voir elle va tomber.
"Aliénor" : Mais quel est ce couloir étrange et sombre ?! *Bruit du trou qui s'ouvre et d'Aliénor qui chute*
*Bruitage de la téléportation*
"Iris" : Oh putin !
"Eliott" : Elle a de la chance, elle s'est téléportée avant de tomber dans les pics au fond.
"Imhotep12" : Mais avec quelle magie avez-vous déjoué mon piège ?
"Thomas" : Je vous l'avais dit pour le trou.
"Iris" : Oh merde, elle est encore partie avec ma machine.
"Thomas" : Allez Imhotep12, on peut avancer maintenant ?
"Eliott" : Tu as une bonne capacité d'analyse Thomas.
"Thomas" : Oh c'est rien, ça fait 20 ans que je joue aux jeux vidéos c'est toujours la même chose.
"Thomas" : Hey ! Regardez, Aliénor a fait tomber les clefs ! Ça va peut-être nous servir.
"Iris" : Ça m'étonnerait que les clefs de la geôle d'une frégate du XVIIIème siècle nous soit d'une quelconque utilité. Ha j'espère que tout va bien pour La Buse.
*Musique de transition*
"La Buse" : C'est quoi ce truc tout blanc ?
"Cleopatre" : C'est un bain de lait. Viens me rejoindre.
"La Buse" : Ah euh, ah c'est étrange.
"Cleopatre" : C'est la première fois que tu prends un bain de lait?
"La Buse" : C'est la première fois que je prend un bain. Hein ? C'est quoi ce truc clair sur ma peau.
"Cleopatre" : C'est ta peau justement
"La Buse" : Je l'avais jamais vu. Oh, regarde le bain à cause de moi il devient chocolat au lait. J'ai vu ça chez des amis les mayas.
"Cleopatre" : J'adore ton côté sale, maintenant mon cochon, ce que tu vas faire, c'est que tu vas me mettre ton gros..
*Musique de transition*
"Thomas" : On met la pièce en forme de L ici, celle en forme de S là, et enfin la longue barre.
*Porte qui s'ouvre*
"Thomas" : Voila
"Iris" : Quoi ?!
*Encore un bruit d'Eliott..*
"Thomas" : Super la musique
"Eliott" : Ça me fait plaisir.
"Imhotep12" : J'en reviens pas ! Mes énigmes !
"Iris" : Super ! On avance !
"Imhotep12" : Mes précieuses énigmes ! J'ai travaillé dessus toute ma vie !
"Iris" : Désolée d'avoir doutée de toi Thomas. Tu t'en sors très bien.
"Thomas" : Bah euh, merci. Attention à la tête.
*Déclenchement d'un piège ( bruit de lame ) *
"Thomas" : J'ai l'impression d'avoir fait ça toute ma vie. Sauf que normalement j'ai une manette dans les mains.
Dis-moi Iris, j'ai une question à te poser.
"Iris" : Je sais, pourquoi je t'ai quitté du jour au lendemain ?
"Thomas" : Non non non. Ah ! On s'arrête une seconde pour les flèches.
*Encore un autre piège qui rate*
"Thomas" : Je me demandais, pourquoi t'es sortis avec quelqu'un comme moi ?
Je vois bien qu'on a rien à voir, je suis moche, je suis pas très intelligent, j'ai aucune culture générale
"Iris" : C'est vrai, enfin, c'est vrai qu'on a rien à voir.
Je sais pas trop Thomas. Il y a quelque chose de sincère au fond de toi que j'ai jamais vu ailleurs.
Je peux aussi te poser une question ?
"Thomas" : Bien sûr. Ah ! Vite sur le côté, on laisse passer la grosse boule.
*La bou-boule qui roule*
"Imhotep12" : Mais, mais c'est pas possible ! Mais comment ..
"Iris" : Pourquoi tu nous suis dans cette aventure ? T'es plutôt du genre à éviter les situations délicates et à rester chez toi.
"Imhotep12": Mais, mais comment il fait ?!
"Thomas" : C'est vrai que je suis pas courageux mais quand je suis avec toi, j'ai l'impression que je peux me dépasser.
La je, je me sens utile pour la première fois de ma vie.
"Iris" : Je comprend. *petit moment de surprise* La relique ! Elle est là !
"Imhotep12": Oh merde ! Mais déjà comment ils ont fait !
"Iris" : Mais c'est le collier que mon père m'avait offert quand j'étais enfant.
Ça brille mais c'est du toc
"Eliott" : Je récupère la relique.
"Imhotep12" : Nan nan ! Nan nan ! Attendez ! Il reste encore une énigme ! Ahah !
Écoutez moi bien ! Vous avez tout le temps que vous voulez pour y répondre, mais une seule proposition sinon vous serez enfermés ici. *Toujours son rire fou*
Qui suis-je ? Le matin, je marche sur quatre pattes. Le midi, je..
"Thomas" : C'est l'Homme! Allez ! La relique !
"Imhotep12" : Mais je viens de l'inventer ! Merde ! Laissez moi au moins terminer mes énigmes !
Il, il reste encore une épreuve, re-regarder ce ce grand feu là. Il faut rester euh... Euh ... Une minute dans les flammes !
"Iris" : Mais n'importe quoi, cette épreuve existe pas, vous venez de foutre le feu à des buches !
"Imhotep12" : Mais pas du tout ! Ah vous abandonnez c'est ça ? *rire* Alors pas de relique, j'ai gagné.
"Thomas" : Mais personne peut survivre dans des flammes, c'est de la triche là.
"Imhotep12" : Mais non je ne triche pas, vous avez perdu c'est tout.
"Iris" : Bah, si c'est une vraie épreuve, vous pouvez la surmonter ? Alors allez-y.
"Imhotep12" : Mais, mais oui c'est une vraie épreuve. Et regardez. Et hop. *Imhotep12 saute dans les flammes*
Voila maintenant il faut attendre une minute, je vais gagner.
* Il crie un peu par ci par là *
Je, j'arrive plus à respirer ! *cris étouffés*
"Eliott" : *Bruit de scanner* Signal vital éteint.
"Thomas" : Et maintenant on prend la relique !
"La Buse" : Mes amis ! Il faut quitter cette endroit !
"Iris" : Bah, La Buse, qu'est c'tu fais là ? Tu fais pas tes jeux sexuels avec la reine ?
"La Buse" : Me parler plus d'elle ! Elle m'a vidée de toute mon énergie, je vais mourir de fatigue si ça continue.
Partons ! Avant qu'elle ne me retrouve ! Elle m'a forcée pour que je rentre entièrement mes deux..
"Iris" : Hop hop hop hop, on veut pas en savoir plus. La Buse, tu t'es fait abuser. Eliott, analyse la relique.
"Eliott" : J'aurais bien voulu connaître la suite moi.
Analyse.
J'ai trouvé la balise temporelle à l'intérieur du collier.
Décryptage en cours, les données m'indique qu'une dernière balise se trouve ailleurs à une autre époque.
"Iris" : Parfait ! On s'y rend tout de suite !
"Eliott" : Re-Temporalisation imminente.
*Thomas : Yes !* Restez près de moi !
"Thomas" : On va où ?
*Cris de Cleopatre au loin*
"La Buse" : Oh non ! La folle revient !
*Toujours plus de cris de la folle*
"La Buse" : Partons mes amis ! Je vous en supplie. Partons !
*Et encore des cris..*
*Bruitage de la téléportation sans oublier la petite musique*
"Eliott" : Et voila !
Tout le monde est bien là ?
"Iris" : Iris présente !
"La Buse" : Je suis avec vous mes amis !
"Eliott" : Nous sommes au complet.
Donc nous voila.
"Thomas" : Moi aussi je suis, j'suis là hein.
"Eliott" : Ah, oui.
Donc nous sommes actuellement, au japon, en 1150, dans le, Palais du Shogun.
"Thomas" : Le Sho-quoi ?
C'est qui ?
"Inconnu" : Étranger ! Que faites-vous dans mon palais ?!
"Eliott" : C'est
Lui.
"Voix off" : Comme quoi les nombreuses heures passées à jouer aux jeux vidéos peuvent vous sortir d'une situation délicate.
Ça arrive pas souvent, mais ça arrive.
Désormais nos compagnons se retrouvent dans l'époque féodale du japon.
Dans le palais du dirigeant militaire.
Vont-ils retrouver la troisième relique du docteur Simon.
"Cyprien" : Merci d'avoir écouter, le septième épisode de l'épopée temporelle.
N'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air et à la semaine prochaine !